as we start our live streaming
all right
and welcome to everyone uh
we have our expert webinar
in trends and ai and ml
uh
artificial intelligence machine learning
uh data science and analytics for 2022.
and our presenter today is ronald van
loon the ceo of intelligent world
advisory board member here at simply
learn and one of uh the
world's leading
recognized experts and speakers on the
topics of
data science and aiml
so before we
get to ronald i'd like to remind
everybody
how to use
the controls for webex please do put
your questions for ronald into the q a
box you can put those in at any time we
will
cue those up for him and i'll be asking
those on your behalf at the q a portion
of the webinar
you can
put messages into chat
but if they're questions for ronald
please put them in the q a
and
that i'd like to start with a poll of
the audience
where we're gonna ask
what skills you would uh what's your
current
uh gotta
gotta change this poll i'm sorry
apologize
i want to make sure the poll i give you
is the one one that matches your
what's on the screen here so
apologize for this delay
always not up
and again i apologize for the delay but
here's the poll if you're watching
on live stream you can put the answers
into the comments but if you are
on the webex session you should see the
widget right now
we asked the second question how you're
feeling today um
been asking that
during the entire pandemic to make sure
that uh
people are
handling lockdowns and
restrictions hoping you're all doing
well today
and i'm going to go ahead and close the
pole
share the results with you
so
we have
a number of students here today
and the number of people in other
positions
besides the practicing
data science
engineers managers
um
also good to see
that
almost everybody is
either doing well or
doing okay
we hope we'll help
improve the outlook of the people in the
third category there
so with that
a little bump in the road i'd like to
introduce
ronald van loon
again one of the foremost thought
leaders in data science and digital
transformation
and we'll go right ahead into
the recap of 2021 trends
um we've had the state of ai investments
with companies
76 of organizations barely breaking even
on their ai investments
ronald do you want to comment on that
yeah it's it's amazing that's i think
it's it's great that we can have time
now to look back look back to 2021 which
was uh on one hand a difficult year from
technology perspective i think quite an
exciting year
and from yeah let's say it's a
foundation again for all the trends that
we see in in 2022
and indeed if we look to some statistics
um where we see where
many organizations start working with
with ai and invest in it
but unfortunately we see and that may be
surprised many people is that 76 of the
organizations they barely break even on
their ai investment
that looks let's say as some kind of
negative news but i think there's also a
lot of positive news about this is that
companies are embracing and increasing
their investments in ai
including ai for for new use cases as
well
and to maximize those type of ai
investments we see that businesses are
turning to to new talent to build top
performing algorithms and i think that's
that's very good for you and i saw many
students so everybody who is
working in the ai domain and data
science domain um i think the outlook is
is fantastic
and what we see to organizations as well
is that they are also evaluating the
cost of ai and they can think about the
cost for for example for computing power
which is much more available all the
time and now we get even high
performance computing computing hpc
available in in the clouds which makes
the
amount of possibilities really
exponential
and we see that many organizations are
choosing an operating model that drives
consistencies in the data approach so
data analytics
ai is incorporated in every organization
and this
leads us to to another trend that we
have heard a lot about in in the past
year i think is mlop machine and
operations
ml ops is
some kind of road map or a framework
that helps businesses to implement best
practices and helps them to implement
technologies for enabling ai and what we
see as well is that ml ops helps
organization to speed up ai application
development and scale ai across the
business and the scaling is
very difficult and it really changed in
the trend many organizations had the
last let's say three years quite some
challenges in scaling ai across the
business and now you see that more and
more organizations have a right
foundation for this and what we see with
this scaling is that this includes
scaling from the tools and it includes
the scaling from the platforms but also
from the services and it helps them to
standardize and to automate the
processes that bring ai teams clarity
and consistency in their roles and in
their responsibility and i think that's
where ml ops really helps
and it incorporates also the data
management the development the workflow
deployments model deployment and model
monitoring as well so we see that
envelopes is really helping
organizations to increase the
productivity
with the
data teams with the machine learning
teams so that they can go live with
their ai solutions as quickly as
possible and really have the possibility
and the option to scale ai fast and i
think that's key in making ai successful
so the the last recap
for 2021 i want to discuss is the
responsible ai
and the more businesses implement ai
solutions into their organizations the
more integral it becomes in ensuring
that outcomes are are positive because
ai consequences can be very negative is
if ai ethical considerations are left
unchecked so ai ethics is really one of
the most important considerations for
organizations
but for management it's
quite some kind of vague
area where it's very hard to control
and for for the machine learning
engineers i think it's crucial to have
this in mind but it's easy to
to forget or or not to put attention on
but it's really really critical and the
reason is that bias can lead to damage
to a business reputation
loss in revenue but i think this damage
in reputation is really critical and it
can
lead to productivity stalls
so organizations are trying to bring
more levels of transparency and equality
into their ai systems and into their
model so i'm talking about
responsible ai as
our final 2021 trend because i think a
ethical ai is always going to be one of
the most important aspects and
foundations for ai
this year also next year and yeah
probably the the coming years and it's
really the foundation whether ai
is going to be for the good um in the
coming years and will be accepted as a
technology that drives basically
everything where data is used so
this sums up most of the popular 2021
trends
but let's start talking about 2022
and
we have
let's see
okay now it works um we have some really
interesting 2022 trends i think to
discuss 2022 will be another year that
further impacted by by data analytics
and ai technologies
building on the foundation that has been
created and what we see is that the
world has shifted to remote work and and
hybrid remote work scenarios
and businesses are still trying to
navigate this new technologies
environments as they continuously
aspire to be ahead or
of this
digital transformation goals that they
have this transformation has really um
speed up
the last year in the last let's say 18
24 months already
and what we see is that supply chains
are in a state of disruption
we've seen it all over the world that
supply chains has been
affected whether it was by covet or
whether it was by a ship in the sewers
canal and we see that organizations are
looking to to virtualize and to
modernize the supply chain environments
and their processes and overcome the
legacy systems that have been in place
sometimes even more than 30 years
so organizations also have to think
about
the impact of the business on the
environment and how they create create
sustainability standards for the
products and for the services and also
create this in their operation
so organization also driven by
regulations and whether that's from the
environment such as we have this paris
accord maybe you have heard about this
um where where we talk about the
sustainability goals that we have or
other data and ai regulations and i
think it's needless to say that 2022 is
going to be another year
where businesses have a lot on their
plate to consider and especially from
this regulation part as well and they
have to figure out how to overcome
disruption from all different kind of
angles where different organizations
from different industries start to
compete with each other and really
determine
the future impact of
their decision that they make every day
and whether that be from implementing
new technologies or
partnering with with vendors partnering
in ecosystems
and of course hiring and upskilling
talent which is really crucial
but also shifting their cultural mindset
and the way that they work and this will
impact their business six months from
now but also yeah let's say a half a
year from yeah from now five years from
now every decision they take now has has
an important impact and businesses need
to look to the future
now more than ever with all these
different changes and fast moving
environments
and ensure that the changes that they
make today will set them up for a future
of success and ensure that they ensure
their business continuity
so that's why i think we're here today
and we're here to talk about the future
of business and what they need to do to
remain relevant to remain competitive
and where we're going to talk about this
four different topics today which i see
as the four main trends which is cyber
security which is decision intelligence
which is generative artificial
intelligence and as the last topic i
would like to discuss is the data fabric
and i'm really excited to being here and
thanks again simply learn and
steward for for inviting me
and um yeah let's uh let's dive into the
discussion but this is uh i think uh
where we're going to talk about stuart
great um and so the you know the key
question i think everybody's thinking of
is
of all the trends what's the most
important in 2022 uh in your opinion and
why is that
yeah it's a trend
i think it's already the most important
right now and especially i think the
last six months we have seen cyber
security becoming top of mind with on
one hand and tons of breaches but also
hacks um and and um
let's say hex where where the hackers
ask for ransomware
and so it's
it's really top of mind and it can
really change your business in a
fraction of a day and so that's why
cyber security is really top of mind for
for any organization today whether you
are
a business around the corner small
median enterprise or whether you are a
large organization and operating
globally
and what we see is that people are
working from home and they're accessing
applications and and workloads from
anywhere on their preferred device and
home networks you can imagine they're
not as secure as the business networks
and also what we see is that business
data business data is in the cloud and
is less often stored on premise and to
top of it all i think organizations
partner with vendors and collaborate
with third-party affiliates and they
need to share more data need to share
more system
which makes it
makes it a bigger challenge to be secure
and i did some research um there's the
famous consultancy firm which is
mckinsey and they mentioned there are
127 new devices connected to the
internet every second and currently we
are close to the 30 billion connected
devices to to the internet and you can
see i think where i'm going with this
there's
a very generalized
scenario but this point is that there's
a lot going on in business in the
business world that can create potential
risk to cyber security because every
connection is basically a potential risk
so we have
globally 30 potential
connections and potential risks which
are daily operating with with the
internet and what we see as well is that
businesses digitize so if they digitize
there's a corresponding need to protect
the customers to protect your employees
to protect your organization
so therefore
cyber security requires on one end a
cultural shift
but also yeah dedication of the board of
the sea level of the employees and
everybody needs to work together to
protect to detect and to respond to
incidents
and to give you a little bit of an idea
what the cost is of cyber crime
that's 10.5 trillion by 2025 so that's a
gigantic amount basically that that we
see
um
and that's something yeah that we need
to keep in mind and that's why it is
so so important so businesses have to
create
cyber security
and a risk response strategy that helps
them to be agile and adaptable in the
face of this
evolving threat landscape and what we
see
is not only the business exchange but
also
let's say the hackers change and they
evolve quickly as well especially during
the pandemic they start focusing doing
more online as they are more limited
offline i believe
and this includes if you look to this
evolving landscape this includes going
over your infrastructure this includes
identifying technologies that can create
this type of vulnerability and you can
imagine if there's only one
vulnerability
you have a risk
and they need to outline a proper
response plan for this so it's important
to
to detail your governance to dedicate
and define responsibility so that people
have a plan to follow
such as rules such as processes and
roles that are delegated to ensure the
privacy and ensure their compliance so
this gives a more consistent view of
data and i think also ensures better
data quality and it helps also create a
single source of truth while defining
methodologies that can be applied to
data management best best practices so
this brings us to
i think our first major point of cyber
security trend discussion and that's
creating a zero trust framework or a
zero trust architecture and probably you
have heard about it the last let's say
six to eight months where key
organizations launched this this concept
where they um where identity and where
devices and network and applications
need to be proven that they are trusted
so every connection in the full stack
is a risk and where they say every
device every identity every network is
basically a risk and this assumes that
everything related to the network
is potentially hostile or it can be
potentially harmful and this required on
one end constant verification
authentication it requires multi-factor
authentication it requires for example
network segmentation and conditional
application access
to protect
all the different layers so ongoing
device management that includes how
devices are accessing your corporate
networks
so if we talk about the zero trust
security
it ensures that resources and data are
accessible and ensure that
interaction between the networks between
the applications
meets this conditional requirements to
be trusted
and oftentimes in case of cyber security
breaches it's
personal identifiable customer data
that's impacted and this causes
yeah reputational damage damage you can
imagine if your data is shared
you shared it with the company and they
lost it in a bridge
yeah you are not feeling comfortable and
this really damages brands um yes often
globally if they have a global
reputation so just a small issue can
have a big big impact on their um
on their reputation and on the other
hand of course it exposes the consumer
to all kind of unnecessary risk if they
don't have it
in order so what's very interesting is
that as analytics and ai advances across
the business we see as well that cyber
criminals also are using ai and
analytics just like the businesses do so
it's always a cat and mouse play
and they
basically illegally access customer data
on the dark web for example or via data
breaches or they do work on social
engineering scam or phishing scam or
other sophisticated and difficult to
detect schemes that they use and
this is a strong driver of cyber
security technology adoption
and the motivator for business to to
have their act together so companies
need to to leverage intelligent
technologies to to combat the cyber
criminals that work with intelligent
technologies as well as i said it's a
get a mouse play all the time before
they can compromise an organization's
customers data for example
and this is an urgent priority now
you need to protect your customer and
you need to protect your your
organization against it and businesses
want to protect the customer privacy and
so they can create a zero trust
framework to help them understand the
data landscape as as well as the data
lineage to secure the data sharing for
example and in the use and to take care
for the access management to get the
care for the activity monitoring but
also to automate responses like consent
management or breach
to breach response for for their privacy
so if organizations
are to succeed with this zero trust type
of approach they have to be prepared to
respond back to the customers who are
requesting information about their
personal information and tell them how
they are using it and how organizations
are storing their personal information
next to that is also important for
businesses to make frequent assessments
about their data and how it's classified
for example who accesses that data who
owns the data
or where knowing that data is being
stored all these aspects are crucial
that they are in control of the
different types of stages of the data
and zero trust
if they have it in place this this
approach it has a lot of benefits um it
reduces the friction and and it works
from basically from anywhere as we now
work from anywhere from any device so
think about the way we started this
conversation talking about employees
needing
to access
do their to their work on any device on
any location probably you work from home
as well
right now and you use your your own
devices whether it's your your tablet
your desktop your mobile
or your smartphone you use devices which
you normally were not allowed to use
probably
at your office
also what's important is the
authentication protocols that help
employees to sign in
and they help them to verify who they
are and
they can start their work immediately so
it doesn't take 10 minutes to login so
employees can easily access the systems
and the tools they need when they are
when they are at home or when they even
are back in the office and of course
this zero trust
is
very secure it's very safe and it helps
you to reduce and to narrow
the exposure to threats and i think it
emphasizes a more proactive approach to
cyber security than the rather a
reactive approach and as it's a cat and
mouse play you have to be the the cat
and you have to stay in advance
of the cyber criminals
but there's also i think a lot of
challenges when it comes to cyber
security that businesses are facing you
can think about security professionals
that have too many tasks to do if you
are one of the security professionals
are i saw there's many students in in
the webcast today if you want to be this
cyber security professional
you will notice that they put a lot on
your plate there's tons of data
and often
these teams they're not always
well equipped because the developments
are going so fast and it's not so easy
to stay up to date and ai is having a
major impact on cyber security and on
the people
as it supports it supports in ensuring
your accuracy and detection
it supports in speeding up the
investigation processes and automating
the response if there's a breach or a
hack so ai can respond often much faster
than people can
so ai is really helping proactively to
respond to threats
uh providing authentication so
just an example is this providing an
authentication based on behavioral
biometrics for individual users
where ai is really helping
so i consider cyber security as the most
important trend of 2022 because business
are continuously emits this digital
transformation initiative and they need
to introduce and implement new
technologies and every new technology
is a new
challenge
to stay safe and to to approach this
from a zero trust perspective so we see
new things like the rise of
cloud of course cloud capabilities which
expose organizations to new potential
risk on the other hand
many activities are managed in the cloud
better than on premise and it reduces
the required amount of skills that
companies need needed
but also we see
customer behavior changing which is a
challenge and they are online more than
ever before they're making a lot of
digital purchases and different digital
activities and interactive where in
interacting with financial institutions
for your banking purposes a mobile bank
of course and
these
every access needs to be secure
we also discussed how employees behavior
are changing too as this work from home
and if we stack up all these different
challenges i think yeah you you can
imagine um how
uh what kind of challenge it is for
organizations so a digital world filled
with with new technologies and data
requires better security more encryption
better skills probably from the teams
and more support from ai and improved
access control
and
this results in a lot of different job
opportunities and different career roles
in cyber
in cyber security
so if you like it it's definitely an
area
to look at it and especially the many
students that are on the webcast today
have a look in cyber security defined
your for for yourself which industries
you like
which aspects of cyber security you like
and based upon this yes start your
career and and
move forward and it's definitely a
career where you can make great money
where you can be
challenged a lot from from all the new
developments and you can think from
being a cyber security architect or an
engineer or a technician or an
administrator
or a security analyst so there's many
different type of tasks and for every
different skill yeah there's a different
type of role so
i think stuart this is a great area for
the students for the people that are
already in the business or already a
data scientist or data analyst to to
watch it and to develop themselves in it
so my first trend
yeah thank you uh ronald and uh
as you mentioned cat and mouse i was
thinking of a different metaphor of the
snake and the mongoose
the uh
the question is
whether you're going to be the the spake
and attack or
the mongoose who not only
fends off the attack but counter-attacks
and kills the snakes
in the netherlands luckily we don't have
snakes we have mouses and we have
right
um
so when we look at
one of the things you mentioned in as a
trend decision intelligence
and
that's an area that i actually
i worked for a company in that area a
few years back
um so it's a very interesting topic to
me but can you
tell more uh tell the audience more
about decision intelligence what it is
and and how that will
change the world of work and improve
yeah good good let me first try to to
clarify what it is and because i can
imagine that it's not clear for
everybody especially if you haven't
worked in that domain it's basically
evaluating possible outcomes and choices
that a person can make and on the other
hand
you gather all the information that's
available in order to make the best
decision that that you can and decision
intelligence i think it's
practice so businesses
now more than ever
they if they look to the future they're
going to be using decision intelligence
as a way to study decision making
and garnering feedback in a way that
helps them to improve the decision
outcomes and ultimately enhance yeah
their
competitive edge their competitive
advantage and the better decisions they
can make with the help of data with the
help of ai the better they they can
compete and decision intelligence helps
better understand the impact
of their decision and how it affects the
different aspects of a business and you
can imagine that every decision you make
whether it's c level executive level or
whether it's
at the practitioner level every decision
you make has an impact on the future and
data is a very important part of this
process and decision intelligence
provides that connection and its
intersection between
the data between the decision making
between the business intelligence and
the management
and ai is therefore an important part of
decision intelligence as being used to
make predictions about future outcomes
so identify potential opportunities
but also identify potential risk and
help the decision maker to evaluate
the best strategies to take
it is however currently very difficult
to get
deep levels of context from data and ai
models and really building and
understanding the connections between
your systems and performing detailed and
complex analysis to make
decisions fast and there's so many
aspects that that you need to take in
into account and this is essentially why
decision intelligence is an integral
part for the future of of business for
the future of work and decision
intelligence helps you helps you to
understand this underlying complexities
of machine learning models and different
inputs so that organizations and
business decision makers can predict
yeah the best possible outcome because
that's what what it's all about and to
give an example organizations might want
to create new market opportunities in
real retail
and
that help them to to adjust their
inventory levels and predict the
consumer demand at the certain times of
the year and if we look back let's say
to the last year from the pandemic the
consumer demand shifted from one day to
the other from let's say physical retail
to online and then
retail could open again back to physical
retail party online and so you can
imagine
it's very hard for
for ai for the data
to look back and to use this data in
their decision-making because it's
there's no
history of reference anymore
another example might be for example
where an insurance organizations who
need to identify risk by by demographics
such as location so if you live in a big
city um or let's say a bad area where
there's a lot of criminality
um you can have a different insurance
than you live in a very safe area maybe
in the countryside where unless this is
happening it's not let's say that's
always that the case but
just as an example so that they can
create products and services which are
very targeted to specific audiences that
fit within the segments and which are
calculated based upon this decision
intelligent so decision intelligence is
a very outcomes focused practice
it's revolving around how business
decisions are going to impact business
goals and how they're going to impact
business use cases so it can be applied
for
many different industry use cases as you
can imagine and businesses need to make
complex decisions and they often need to
make them as quick as possible
and decision intelligence helped them to
reduce the time it takes to developing
and to deploying this complex business
logic
at the same time
if we look to business leaders and
decision makers they need to resolve
this discrepancies in decision-making
best practices and
all the different type of components and
circumstances surrounding the nature of
this decision and
you can imagine how complex every
decision it is because it has an impact
on every aspect of your business every
aspect what your your client does so
it's a very complex area
for um
let's say in in the domain of ai and
what we see is that successful
organizations they are very ai and
analytics driven
the biggest examples of course are the
teslas and the amazons of this world and
we see as well that
many organizations now
focus with their work environment to a
hybrid or even a digital type type of
workforce so organizations are exploring
this ongoing digital transformation they
want to learn how to meet this involving
consumer needs and this consumer
expectations and the the customer
expectations
and
based upon this they need to react they
need to
be ready to be resilient
in any type of description that that's
gonna occur
and we've seen different disruptions
right now go with his dark over this
back
and it's going up and down and other
things happening
where they need to respond to and if we
look to ai and analytics landscapes in
this domain
they are complex
so it is connecting businesses needs
with the ai and the machine learning
models which is the complex part and
decision intelligence helps to
strengthen
that connection between the
decision-making process and the ai such
that by building distrusted and accurate
ai outcomes or eliminating the bias in
the human decision making and yeah as i
said you can imagine this is a complex
area but from the other hand it's an
interesting area to be in
if you're a student now as well look at
this area next to the cyber security
because this is an area that's going to
have a big impact and there's going to
be a huge need from from skill sets in
in the coming time and if we look to
organizations it's the entire
organization from board level executives
management
and i.t
they're all becoming connected and
involved in supporting business decision
makings in goals and objectives they're
doing this already but they get now um
in contact with this automated decision
intelligence and that
includes working together to optimize
the potential of their data and ai
if we look to the future of work this
all revolves around the business and the
technology teams
which are uniting more and more it's
less department driven is more outcome
driven and supporting each other to
drive these business goals and to meet
your company objective and what we see
is that decision intelligence is the
link
together to these disparate teams and
their data and help the analytics
professionals better apply data science
practices into the context of the
business problem
decision intelligence is not just going
to improve the future of work but it
will become a necessity and everyday
practices organizations seek to drive
this competitive advantage and and
growth and using data and ai
and
once again if you
looking to develop your skill sets
in this domain um in the in the new
trends this is one of the trends you can
look at
and yeah for sure there there is a
future for the skills that that you're
going to go going to get so
this is my second important trend and i
think it's
it's really helping the
people over here
yeah if you take a look at the
next slide you probably
um
what we're
looking for the third trend then is
something you're calling generative
artificial intelligence
which is
kind of a new term for me um but i've
seen what your explanation is so
i'm looking forward to you sharing that
with the audience and especially
as
as the question puts it how
how can you use that in a practical
sense how is it applied in different
industries
as a new way of
applying artificial intelligence
business problems
let me
maybe explain because you
you have seen what what it is but not
everybody has seen it so if we look to
generative ai it creates
new data instances from the data that
has already been trained from
available audio from available text from
images and videos and basically
generative ai takes audio text and
images and videos and creates
new content from it
so everyone has probably already seen
how ai generated images of people who
don't exist
and so
now the metaverse has been been let's
say announced
if we look to these type of images the
images look real but the people are not
real
and or
you can also think about how numbers
look like
if they are yeah like handwritten by by
person but they are not handwritten so
they are these are common examples of
generative ai
so generative ai is being sorry
i was going to just mention another
example of this and it relates to a
question that came in about the role of
ai in the race for the coronavirus
vaccine
there's
one of the problems with machine
learning is you need large data sets to
train
machine learning systems
and
sometimes for example especially in
healthcare
the real data the real world data is
restricted because of privacy concerns
so it's important to have a way to
generate
data that behaves as if it was real
world data but is actually artificially
generated
so that there's no actual privacy being
violated and that's an example very nice
yeah so we see as well indeed that
during the pandemic for um the covet 19
treatment this has been
been used as well and i really like like
the example
i think another term for it is synthetic
data which we will hear in the coming
time more and more
so we see that this type of technology
helped to aids research with this covet
as it helped to generate more more data
to support this existing algorithms and
i like the example of privacy or privacy
sensitive type of data and this way you
can indeed generate
data
that is synthetic
and therefore not reaching any type of
privacy regulation and indeed healthcare
can benefit a lot from this generative
ai in other applications as well from
early detection and identifying certain
illnesses and indeed again by using
synthetic data not privacy
sensitive type of data
but also for example for analyzing
different x-ray images to better
visualize
patient ailments for example so generate
generative ais
also not only used in healthcare it's
also used for example in manufacturing
for rapid prototyping to to build
and to model potential new new products
um which improves the
basically the existing prototyping and
speeds up the existing prototyping or
versions to to fine-tune um existing
prototyping and i've seen let's say
examples where they prototyped a full
factory
um and they run the full factory already
before it's even built
and then they start producing and then
let's say creating the products that are
built in in the factory so this is the
level where you can think about and a
nice example was a bmw that that runs
the the factories like this and you can
imagine that if you can fully operate
your factory before it's built
in a digital environment and you can
test it already this speeds up much
faster than doing this this in practice
we also see let's say many other
industries that are going to be
effective by this generative ai such as
media and entertainment
the automotive example
which i had but also aerospace and
energy and it will disrupt
also the software and and the coding
domain and i think this is very
important for for our audience because
it can automate up to 70 percent of the
work
done by programmers and if you
think now about your career and you are
a programmer think about okay what if 70
of my tasks are going to be automated so
how do you need to develop your skill
set
and your experience
so it's helpful for the organizations
that are going to automate the the
coding and generative ai will be playing
a big part in in this it is fairly new
technology
as
you mentioned as well stuart but as
organizations mature in ai and further
explore and adopt new ai solutions
generative ai is going to be one of the
dynamic technologies that organizations
implement for various use cases and
one important trend what we see now as
mentioned in the beginning
we have high performance computing
initially it was only there for research
institutions maybe for
large financial institutions or for
governments that had the power to
thousands of cores which they could
scale at once
now hpc computing becomes available in
the cloud
which means that if there's much more
compute power
they can run
a thousand-fold
faster the algorithms and which means
that these type of developments goes
very very fast and
we've seen the announcements for example
from nvidia in in the meta versus as
well um
the foundation is getting there and if
if you have a road
then people start driving over the road
and start driving faster now there is a
new type of let's say compute power
level which means that the number of
applications
will exponentially grow the coming time
and this generative ai is um is an
important part of this there's also
challenges when it comes i think to
generative ai and they require what we
mentioned already a lot of training data
and to give to give some examples
um
if you have a company would obtain a
very large and comprehensive data set
which
are already labeled and this labeling is
very difficult for business context when
building these very use cases um not
just from a standpoint of obtaining the
large data set but also
from responding to all the small
variations that could lead to having to
acquire more data sets and the synthetic
data over here is is a very important
part for for the solution so you can
think about an autonomous vehicle that
needs to navigate a certain area where
weather conditions change constantly
this would require data sets for all the
different types of weather conditions
which makes it impossible so essentially
another challenge is
data labeling because the underlying
data needs to be labeled by by people
initially and generative ai can
also be very
hardware dependent and require a lot of
computing power but that part is solved
basically now more and more because it's
available in the cloud
the other part which is a challenge
stewart which you were mentioning as
well is the privacy concerns um so if
you use privacy sensitive data and for
that yeah we
yeah we discussed the healthcare and on
the other hand there are solutions uh
solutions for this as well
so
if we look to to how it can work
it uses
a generative
that
uses basically the gen networks
which is a type of machine learning
model that generates the samples from
real-world distributions so it's a
semi-supervised learning technique where
two networks compete against each other
and
it's a generator and a discriminator
and these enhance their understanding
of the of this something of the area
which they discover and the generator
learns to produce realistic data where
the discriminator detects the fake data
from the real data and this ultimately
reduces the need for for data to be
labeled by humans because the algorithm
is trained to generate these new
instances based upon smaller trained
human label data sets
which makes it faster to deploy and even
though generative ai is i think still in
this infancy
more and more industries more and more
applications and more and more use cases
will be explored moving into the future
and especially as more
data volume and data sets are created
and this will help to provide a better
foundation for generative ai to operate
if we look from let's say skill set
requirements and
do organizations understand and demand
for this already i think you will be
quite early if you start in this domain
it will be a hot domain
but it's not that demand is there yet
it's only there for
a limited set of organizations who are
very advanced with data with ai
developments
and therefore from
let's say a job perspective
it's nice but it's something a little
bit more into the future to to take a
benefit of so that's i think
why generative ai is is the third trend
that
i wanted to raise today
okay
and let's quickly talk about data
fabrics which is a
interesting emerging area and
we want to get to some q a if we can i
know that you have a hard stop
at the
bottom of the hour for us at the top of
the hour for our indian audience um
but can you tell us more about
data fabrics in their application
yeah data fabric is is a concept which
is already there for a long long time
and
if we look to some description of from
gartner for example data fabric they
describe it as a design concept that
serves as an integrated layer or fabric
of data and connected processes that
let's say the general description but
the data fabric uses continuous
analytics
over um existing metadata to design and
to to deploy the data across their
environment so this improves data
management by automating repetitive
tasks um so a data fabric architecture
requires a data management platform and
this data management platform integrates
the data management capabilities of the
data that's on premise that's on the
hybrid cloud that's in your multi-cloud
and it facilitates a business
facilitates a business data for your
applications for your automation and for
your analytics so organizations what we
see is that they are experiencing data
integration challenges and as more
databases are added data integration
becomes more difficult and data is often
disparate across all different kinds of
locations different clouds different
vendors
different partners and we see there's
also let's say an increasing regulatory
requirements and compliance policies
pertaining to the data and organizations
need to
to integrate and derive the meaning from
the data and data fabric is then the
architecture that addresses the
challenges in the different data
landscape and help them to organizate or
orchestrate the data across these
distributed environments so that the
data is instantly available for the
different business purposes and this
creates then this unified view of your
customer of your business data so
business can better manage their their
data
from a
general perspective and there are
several benefits of such a data fabric
it helps you to protect the data by
automating your governance in the data
platform
by using this metadata to enforce the
data access policies for example
which is also part of your security and
the data fabrics also it facilitates
the use of cell servers and it
democratizes basically your data in your
organization so all the different which
are now maybe departments or rules can
access the data and can use the data
and make make it work for your
organizations that have been having it
stored
on a separate location and to answer
more about the data integration
challenge side of the question data
fabric helps to bring about this
automated data integration so that
organizations aren't spending a lot of
time in manually integrating data and
data integration has been a challenge
let's say for the past 25 years and data
fabric really helps in getting that that
act together and also keep in mind that
organizations
aren't yet
there to realize the full potential of
the data fabric many organizations are
just implementing it working on it
and for many organizations
they are still in their infancy in
really deploying
um the data fabric so it helps
um it helps organizations in their
digital transformation and it helps them
to continuously exploring and new
technology and new ways to use their
data and the data fabric i think is the
solution to create this robust data
architecture that integrates the layers
across the applications the autonomous
database and and the cloud
infrastructure
and
i think yeah it's really the the next
stage of data management data management
is still the the foundation for
everything what you do with data and ai
and machine learning so much time is
spent during this digital transformation
on this expects aspects of the data
integration from let's say
um
the the the people in in the webcast
from job perspective
this is an area which will
never disappear um it's it's critical
and the reason why it's critical yeah
it's the foundation of everything what's
what you do
with your data
so
if you focus on
the the let's say the processes and the
improvements of your data in a data
fabric
it will help and you will get
get the job i think easily if you have
experience in this area because this is
a need for every organization that uses
data
and that means that whatever industry
you are
this domain
has value for for your career
so i think it gives some some time for
questions now
and i think you have so a poll
we have so many questions we'll do the
poll after the questions and answers um
but in the meantime let's get to a few
of the questions um one of them you know
there's several people who are curious
to know if ai is going to displace jobs
and as
just comment what you were saying about
data fabrics as an example
ai seems to be
expanding the possibilities rather than
taking away
existing work yeah it's two things on
one end you have to think okay
what's what are humans humans are
creative um
are creative and they can think not in
in algorithms so think about what you're
good at and if we look to ai the current
status is it's replacing
activities but these are activities
which are a lot of repetitive type of
activities
so if we look to humans humans are great
in creativity
yes um ai will replace certain tasks
and that will let's say go faster and
faster and therefore as a human you need
to think more and more
okay what's my strength what can i do
different i'm creative so how can i use
a i
to augment my skills so i can be more
productive
and deliver faster results so
this is a key reason i think why you
need to stay up to date in all the
developments in data in analytics and ai
is to understand
what's the level
of what can be automated
what's the level how you can be
supported in your job task by ai
and how can you do your job better
so
if you want to survive
keep in mind what ai can help you with
and start using it and use it from your
for your benefit instead of seeing it as
a threat that will replace certain tasks
from you and if we look back to the
industrial revolution it was also
replacing tasks that people were doing
this is happening now as well but at the
faster pace so you need to learn faster
than what you've ever done before but um
yes
technology whether we go 100 years back
or 200 years back what you called it
technology at that moment it was
supporting jobs or you can call it
replacing job i call it augmenting your
job and being more productive
right
um clint is an infosec
engineer
and
he's curious to know where to find
cyber security machine learning
resources that are not just academic
things that are correct
um
and i i don't want to promote my own new
platform but i'm on the intelligent
world we
sure share use cases and all kinds of
real business cases where ai machine
learning is used and
so that that's one of the source
but also i think if yeah depending how
technical or non-technical you would
like to have it um if you are more the
the the kd nuggets and data science
central they're
more basically going to the the
technical part
um if you look more to the
the business side
there's so many different
areas as i said look first at
intelligent world where you can really
find education about it and otherwise i
use a lot twitter and
where you you follow certain hashtags to
stay up to date what's what's going on
it seems to be
let's say
a general source but if you define your
hashtags properly
um i think you get the right use cases
and searching on youtube where you can
find the right use cases and the third
source i think is the technology vendors
itself
they have a lot of educational
programs where they share the use cases
what you can do with the technology and
they will launch every
month every quarter new technology
and the use case is related to that so
they're really willing to share it and
if you subscribe to their webinars you
can educate yourself as well the the
challenge let's say with
subscribing to the vendors type of
broadcast yeah there's quite some
vendors so which vendors to subscribe
but that's something where you need to
define your specific area your specific
industry and find the vendors that are
in that area as well
thank you um
we have several questions from people
who are in
related fields like computer
architecture
electrical engineering who are curious
to know how to move into data science
what kind of path they can take and
whether this is a good opportunity
a good pivot for them
yeah so um
if you let's say if you have a business
focus and you are in a total different
industry
i think the easiest is is to start still
as as a data analyst or as a junior data
scientist and it sounds maybe maybe
strange if you have 10 or 15 years of
experience and
do is maybe you it feels like doing a
step back but maybe you can either do a
course or
have a side role next to your job and
start to understanding what data is what
data can do for you start using the data
um
really from a business perspective
because that brings a lot of business
value to your skills if you have
industry expertise and if you understand
how to analyze data
the the other part which is the good
thing about all the analytics nowadays
is that it's more and more automated so
you can do quite advanced
analysis without understanding the the
real foundation how to do the analysis
um it's always good to understand the
foundation but um i can imagine if you
don't want to to dive into it and do a
full either course or a master in it
so start trying to find the applications
within your organization they are
definitely there where you can start
analyzing your data and start working
with it and the real value for each
person who has industry knowledge is the
combination is
you can understand the industry you can
translate let's say what data
can mean for your organization if you
are a data scientist
without any industry knowledge
it's very hard to one understand the
data and the second part is to
communicate what the data can do for
your organization so
um start with with a small course and
maybe simply learn as well
and
from there from your analytics expertise
or
your data science skills
move further um but yeah keep your
strengths and your strengths is the the
business knowledge
okay
um i know that you have a hard stop now
um and you're gonna have to
disappoint a number of the people who
asked questions
um but i will answer a couple of those
if you need to leave the webinar now um
uh
ronald we'll understand we'll get
get through the rest of
it without you um
so
if that's the case let me know yeah
thanks thanks a lot for everybody and um
hope you enjoyed it and look forward to
seeing you next time and wish you
um all the best in 2022. it's a it's a
nice year ahead with a lot of
developments
and looking from the bright side from
all the opportunities it brings
thanks again ronald thanks um
i'm going to go ahead and run the poll
for
this last
question this will ask what skills you
would like to
add to your
personal toolkit
and
for those skills when would you like to
start learning them
i'll keep the poll open for about
another 20 seconds
i always
like to say that
best time to start is now but
see what you have to say about that in
about five seconds
share the poll results here
so not surprising um
70 percent of you would like to do
add data science skills
followed by ai
and machine learning
and then
some of people are interested in each of
the other skills as well and i know that
there was a question about project
management
and opportunities uh
project management relating to emerging
technologies safely learning does
actually have
uh
courses in both general project
management skills but also in
things like management for digital
transformation that type of thing so
we have
training programs available in all of
these areas and
i take a look at the
answers about time
most people would like to get started
soon so
that's a good thing to know let me
switch over
and finish the webinar for us
so we want to say thank you to ronald
i believe but i will give you his
linkedin
contact information and you'll be able
to
reach out to him
follow or connect with him on linkedin
and
he'll be able to help with some of those
questions
and i'm putting that into the chat
all right
we do have uh
general areas of data science and
analytics courses ranging from single
courses to
comprehensive masters and postgraduate
programs
some of which are in concert
partnership with
major universities
and so i'm putting these links into the
chat as well
you can take a look at more
information about the specific
areas that interest you
and then lastly i'd like to mention that
we have a webinar coming up next tuesday
december 21st
in the digital marketing area it'll be
similar to this one in that we will be
talking about
trends in digital marketing
uh for 2022.
so if you have an interest in that area
or if you know somebody who does please
share that link
and with that i'd like to conclude the
webinar we remind you to connect with us
on
our social media channels
simply learn
at simply learning facebook and twitter
or simply learn on linkedin
a number of questions about things like
certificates and and slides we will be
sharing
um the
basic slide set although it's very very
brief today but we'll share the the 10
slides
about the topic
in a pdf format and we will email you a
link to a recording of the session and
we will
link
uh we'll send you your proof of
attendance certificate if you attended
live on webex
and uh
we're here for more than half of the
webinar
we'll let you email you that proof of
attendance over the weekend so i want to
reassure you about all those things and
thank you all again for being here at
today's webinar
um we hope it was informative and
we look forward to seeing you at future
simply on webinars and hope to welcome
you into the simply learn learning
community
thank you so much
you